having stopped the reach invasion and
broken the light in half the team will
now operate out of the watchtower side
by side with the league
not because Mount Justice was destroyed
but because you earned it
and so we'll leave you to it
this team has had successes but much
remains to be done
Superboy Miss Martian Beast Boy your
alpha
bars or oome has called from Mars he
needs help
tigress Kid Flash bumblebee Guardian
your beta Lex Corp is bringing out the
reach soft-drink under a new name we
need proof business as usual the rest of
your gamma and we'll investigate
batgirls lead on vandal savage's next
move
[Music]
business as usual hey youtubers happy
early holidays new gift young justice
season threes this is gonna be a
breakdown what the hell is going on in
why this is so awesome season three is
happening this is not a joke this is not
a drill
this is totally real Warner Brothers
announced Warner Brothers animation that
they're working on a new season they
didn't announce when it's coming out
what the cast is going to be what
changes that are going to be from the
original series but I think they're
going to try and keep everything in
continuity as much as possible now it's
been about three and a half years since
the season two finale aired there were
20 episodes in season 2 so we can guess
that they might do between 13 and 20
episodes for whatever new season they're
doing they did a really big time jump
between season 1 and season 2
they might just choose to do the exact
same thing for season 3 but they
basically ended the second season like
if you haven't watched in a long time
with a Big Blue Beetle arc where like
the villains of the Blue Beetle comics
like this insectoid race tries to invade
the earth they were able to stop them so
what they might do you know because that
threat was taken care of at the end of
that series is they might choose to do a
rebirth Reformation of the team show
them getting the band back together or
they could just pick up like they never
lost a step it's really easy to do that
with animation because the actors don't
visibly age they can just draw the
characters however old they want to the
funny thing about the season 2 timeline
is that it actually takes place during
2016 so hilariously they could actually
pick up on the next day if they want it
to like 2017 whenever the series ends up
dropping but the thing is is that
animation takes a lot longer to produce
so I would expect a late 2017 mid 2018
like a summer release just depends on
when they start working on it and how
much money they throw into it usually
the faster you try to get stuff out the
bigger the animation team has to be the
cost starts ballooning so I'm just
expecting this late 2017 like maybe a
trailer sometime next year and then a
2018 release at the latest I don't think
it'll be later than that but usually the
easiest thing for them to get out is the
actual screen
the ideas for the stories so that's what
you'll probably hear about at Comic Con
next year if they don't drop a trailer
which they probably will so what they'll
probably do now is that the producers
will slowly start teasing stuff out
until they make an actual reveal like
this is what the team is going to be
here some promo art and then we'll get
some actual footage so let me know where
do you want them to pick up with Episode
one a season three and keep in mind that
they kept this on earth 16 so it was
taking place on a different earth from
the main DC Comics so they could do
Damian Wayne stuff but all the movie
animation stuff that's been happening
recently like they did the Teen Titans
movie about the origin of Raven with
Trigon by their explanation young
justice takes place in a separate
universe so they could mix that if they
want they can totally retcon that but
anything that showed up during season 1
season 2 is fair game
pretty much any DC character it's a lot
easier for them to use really big
characters for the animated series than
it is for the live-action TV shows but
this does throw a little bit of water on
the idea of a live-action Young Justice
TV show because they're doing the
animated series so they probably won't
do those at the same time I know they
have a lot of the Young Justice
characters in the live-action flash
arrow Supergirl TV shows but what they
might choose to do beat you know because
the Teen Titans TV show the TNT was
trying to develop kind of fell through
that that went away they're not making
that anymore they could pick that up on
the CW for whenever arrow goes off the
air but I'm not expecting that to happen
for at least another two years so Merry
Christmas Happy Holidays you know
whatever December holiday it is that you
guys celebrate this is like your first
big present let me know if they're going
to do animated Young Justice what do you
want them to do when arrow goes off the
air on the CW do you want them to do
live-action Teen Titans or do you want
them to actually try for live-action
Young Justice but because they've done
this and even though it's a long ways
off before we're going to get any
footage or a trailer or anything like
that I'm totally happy to do Young
Justice bonus videos so if you do want
any specific things just let me know in
the comments be sure to subscribe to get
everything
this reminds me of when Legend of Korra
went off the air like a beautifully
animated series that was written real
well but it was really expensive and
didn't make a lot of money for
Nickelodeon that's a Nickelodeon show
Warner Brothers did young justice
obviously but the reason they cancelled
Young Justice is because it wasn't
selling any toys and that's how they
monetize the cartoons at that time
typically TV shows earn their money
based on the advertising they sell so
like when you see a commercial during a
TV show the TV show makes money based on
that so the more people watch the higher
the advertising rates the more money the
TV show makes the longer they keep it on
the air but a lot of cable animated
series are different they don't monetize
them like primetime shows so young
justice was built on the strength of its
toy sales they didn't sell so they
canceled the TV show which was a huge
bummer because it was really popular a
lot of people watched it but because
that wasn't their benchmark for success
they still canceled it but they probably
found a smarter way to earn money from
it so that's why they're bringing it
back and because everybody wants it so
Getae it's gonna be awesome just because
this happened I'll post my Walking Dead
video next I'll be doing a Walking Dead
trailer video so that'll either post
later tonight or early tomorrow morning
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for all my Doctor Strange
Easter eggs and you can click here for
the trailer for the next episode of the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight